Don't "hulk out," Marvel fans Mark Ruffalo
isn't actually being fired from the MCU.
But Avengers 4 directors the Russo Brothers
are doing an admirable job keeping a running
gag about Ruffalo's termination going.
It all started back in October, when Ruffalo
apparently slipped up and stated out loud
the actual title of Avengers 4 on the Tonight
Show Starring Jimmy Fallon.
The Russo Brothers and the bigwigs at Marvel
have kept the title top secret, since it's
reportedly a spoiler for the preceding film,
Avengers: Infinity War.
"I think I can probably tell you that."
"Really?"
"I think it's already out there.
The title of the next Avengers movie is [BLEEP]."
The Hulk actor took to Twitter following the
taping to send a tweet to Fallon, asking the
late-night host to have his team edit the
episode and save his hide.
"@JimmyFallon , I trust that you will cut
my spoiler slip on the show tonight.
That was 'off the record' homey.
Please don't get me in trouble with Marvel
(Barry) again.
DM me back.
M."
The supposed spoiler was ultimately censored
and a black bar was placed over Ruffalo's
mouth in the cut that aired on television,
but Joe Russo and his co-directing bro Anthony,
along with Ruffalo, decided to keep the gag
alive online.
Ten days after Ruffalo's apparent misstep,
the Russos uploaded a cryptic photo to their
joint Twitter page, celebrating the end of
filming on Avengers 4.
Ruffalo responded to their tweet, poking fun
at how unfair it is that they can share anything
they want but he got fired for dropping Avengers
4 info.
"You fired me for a measly slip of the title?
Spoiler alert!"
The Russo Brothers then quipped back,
"You're still fired, Mark."
During an Instagram Q&A session held on Thursday,
November 8th at his new bar Duello in Los
Angeles, Joe Russo was asked how he deals
with spoiler-happy actors like Ruffalo.
His bartender asks, "Didn't you fire Mark
Ruffalo?"
To which Russo replies, "Yes, we fired [him].
Mark's fired."
You have to hand it to them: Their commitment
to the joke is impressive!
As for the title that Ruffalo supposedly let
slip on The Tonight Show, one Marvel fan did
some fancy audio-editing and revealed that
Ruffalo told Fallon that Avengers 4 is titled
The Last Avenger — which would neatly connect
to Captain America: The First Avenger from
2011.
"The Last Avenger."
But don't get too excited.
Someone who was in attendance at the Tonight
Show taping shot down the speculation, stating
that the whole thing was "a bit" and that
Ruffalo told the audience during a commercial
break that what he said wasn't true.
"Don't bother!
I was there, after they went to commercial
he said none of it actually happens.
He said something about Bruce finally becoming
the Hulk again (which I hope will happen in
a4!!) having to do with some lava.
But yeah it was definitely a bit."
So while Ruffalo and the Russos have done
excellent work whipping Marvel fans into a
frenzy with their title-teasing antics, it
looks like we'll all have to wait just a little
longer to learn the true title of Avengers
4.
The studio is reportedly holding off on revealing
it until the end of 2018.
As for the film itself, Joe Russo revealed
in his Instagram Q&A that the stakes will
be way higher in Avengers 4, as expected,
and the epic Infinity War follow-up is currently
only half edited, with a ton of painstaking
effects work left to complete.
See the final product when the still-totally-untitled
Avengers 4 hits theaters May 3rd, 2019.